TWILIO:
By now, I think we’re all familiar
with one time passcodes. They’re the pesky but
required 6 digit codes that enable two factor
authentication and keep all of our accounts secure
from hackers and bots. Most of us have likely
never given OTPs much thought, it’s just a normal
part of the modern tech world but it’s actually
a massive industry supporting several massive
players. You of course have your classic tech
companies including Google’s Identity Platform and
Amazon’s Cognito. You’ve probably also heard of
Duo Mobile and Octa but have you ever heard of a
company called Twilio. Twilio is arguably the king
of automated text messages and emails with a peak
market cap of over $70 billion. This means that at
their peak, they were one of the top 250 largest
companies in the world. But, more recently,
things haven’t been looking as bright for this
OTP giant. In fact, Twilio stock has fallen 85%
bringing their market cap all they way down to
just over $12 billion. It’s easy to write off this
decline as just a byproduct of the volatile market
and recession fears but there seems to be more
to Twilio’s story. Not only did they fall much
further than big tech but they have yet to see any
sort of recovery and when you take a look at their
financial reports it all starts to make sense. You
see, Twilio has never been a profitable company,
having relied on VC funding and stock dilution to
keep the business running. This strategy works out
when revenue is growing exponentially but not so
much when revenue starts to stall out and that’s
exactly what’s happening to Twilio whose is very
much stalling out at the $4 billion mark. To make
things worse, it doesn’t seem like their expenses
are getting any better meaning that Twilio is
currently burning well over a billion every
single year. With only $3.5 billion left in the
bank, this is not exactly an ideal situation for
the company and it’s no wonder why investors are
staying away. So, join me as we take a look at the
rise and fall of the king of OTPs and whether
Twilio will ever return to their former glory.
AN UNDERSERVED MARKET:
Taking a look back, Twilio didn’t start
off as an OTP company because well OTPs weren’t
even a thing when Twilio was founded in 2007. The
main guy behind Twilio was a software developer
and serial entrepreneur named Jeff Lawson. Jeff
was a former AWS product manager who was obsessed
with perfecting user experiences. In fact,
Jeff strongly believes that this is the main job
of software engineers, to iteratively understand
customers and build better and better solutions
using software. But despite founding 3 companies
before Twilio, Jeff couldn’t help but feel that
he was constantly falling short in this area,
and to him, the reason was obvious, a lack of
communication. With traditional businesses,
whether its a retail store or a restaurant,
you’re constantly able to interact with your
customers and get a feel for what they like, what
they don’t like, and what could be improved. But,
with software, while you’re able to reach
more customers than any traditional business,
you’re also far more disconnected from your
customers. Aside from a random review that
might pop up from time to time, there was really
no way to directly communicate with customers. So,
Jeff started looking into ways that he could setup
communication infrastructure himself which is when
he ran into a massive reality check. It turns out
that building out a communications platform is far
harder than building out a software platform.
According to Jeff himself, he was used to used
to software development timeslines in the weeks.
Building out this communication infrastructure,
however, would take 2 to 3 years and $2 to
$3 million. Put off by the cost and timeline,
Jeff would start looking into big tech solutions
which is when he realized that there was none,
and that’s when it hit him. If he needed to
communicate with customers, it’s likely that
other developers did as well. And if there
was no established solution on the market,
then maybe he could be that solution. And with
that, we saw the birth of Twilio: a company that
was going to make communications between software
companies and users easier than ever. The journey
to build this company, however, was by no means
easy. The problem was that Jeff needed VC money
and no VC really understood what he was trying to
do. In fact, Jeff started off with what he deemed
to be a safe pitch, a pitch to a person that
he knew pretty well. But this person would end
up laughing Jeff out of the room asserting that
Jeff would need an insane amount of sales people
to get this off the ground. This disappointing
outcome made it clear to Jeff that he needed
proof before he approached VCs, so instead of
pitching, he would get to work. He would build
a voice API that was completely hosted on the
cloud and could make and receive phone calls,
and they would launch it on November 20, 2008.
Keep in mind, this was a couple months before even
Google Voice came out, so Twilio was very much
early to the game. And as such, they were able
to land some pretty big clients pretty quickly.
This included the likes of Cheetos, Earth911,
Tumblr, and Sony Music. It turned out that Twilio
Voice was also super helpful for politicians
who wanted to automate the process of calling
voters. With these customers in his back pocket,
Jeff would return to the VC table and let’s just
say, he would be taken a lot more seriously.
GROWING PAINS:
In early 2009, Twilio would complete a seed
funding round raising $600,000. If you’re familiar
with Chris Sacca from Shark Tank, he was one of
Twilio’s seed investors. They would follow this up
with a Series A round of funding just a couple of
months later raising $3.7 million. Now that Twilio
had money, Jeff would double down on his sales
effort. According to Jeff, the key to growing
Twilio was treating developers like customers.
You see, a lot of enterprise companies get into
the habit of treating developers as second tier
customers, and it’s no wonder why. When you’re
serving developers, considerations like public
reputation and brand image aren’t nearly as
important. Not to mention, there’s only a handful
of developer solutions for any given market, so
developers aren’t that likely to switch to another
service provider in the first place. So, companies
often tend to treat developers as just a strategy
to reach more end users and make their experience
even better. As a software developer, Jeff was all
too aware of this reality and he wanted Twilio to
be different. He wanted Twillio to put developers
first and treat developers as customers and this
has really been their strategy. They would sponsor
hackathons, run hackathons, and hand out a bunch
of shirts to developers. In fact, at one point,
Jeff would make the prediction that Twilio would
hand out more shirts to developers than Blackberry
would ship phones. Looking back, this wasn’t
too hard given that Blackberry would fall off
a cliff but I think you get the idea, Twilio was
reaching a lot of developers. As their reach grew,
Twilio also focused on expanding their product
line which led to the creation of their text
messaging API in February of 2010. Originally,
this wasn’t meant for OTPs. Rather, it was meant
for updating customers. For example, messages like
“Your shipment is on the way” or “Your package is
out for delivery”. It wasn’t till mid 2011 that
Twilio launched their shortcode API platform,
and this is when all of Jeff’s original worries
came back to life. With their voice API and
original SMS api, infrastructure wasn’t too big of
a concern because the volume wasn’t too large. But
with OTPs, companies would be sending millions if
tens of millions of messages on a daily daily. So,
not only did Twilio need strong infrastructure but
they also needed rock solid deals with carriers
to process and send so many text messages. Twilio
also had to worry about preventing spam and abuse
of the platform. To be honest, Twilio never
really figured out the solution to this issue,
but luckily for Twilio, investors had. Back
in 2007, investors didn’t quite understand the
value of Twilio but by the early 2010s, they
knew exactly what they were in for and they
were willing to back Twilio to the moon.
This included $12 million in late 2010,
$17 million in late 2011, $130 million in 2015,
and a $150 million IPO in 2016. This is really how
Twilio addressed the infrastructure problem.
They just raised and spent a bunch of money,
but while that worked in the early days,
as Twilio becomes a mature company,
investors are looking for profitability and ROI
which brings us into Twilio’s current crisis.
A BREAKING POINT:
The reality is that
Twilio is having an extremely rough time achieving
profitability. They’ve already tried doing layoffs
multiple times actually. Last September, they
laid off 11% of their staff and earlier this year,
they laid of another 17% of their workforce. So,
within the past year, they’ve cut their workforce
by almost a third and they’re still burning
over a billion dollars per year. And the reality
is that this situation is more a result of the
industry as opposed to Twilio themselves. You see,
the communications API industry has become
extremely cutthroat especially with Google and
Amazon stepping into the arena. These juggernauts
view the industry in completely different light.
To them, the communications API industry is just
a small portion of one sector of one division of
their business. They frankly don’t care about
this sector more than just controlling it and
telling their enterprise customers that they
offer these solutions as well. Aka, Google nor
Amazon really care about their SMS business being
profitable. For them, it’s all about the bigger
picture. It’s about locking in Walmart or Ford as
their next massive cloud customer. If that means
that Walmart and Ford get subsidized OTPs, so be
it, it’s more than worth it. The same, however,
cannot be said about Twilio who’s main business
itself is communications meaning that this itself
has to be profitable. And according to Twilio
themselves, they don’t expect GAAP profitability
till 2027. With that being said, the good news is
that Twilio has a really strong pool of customers
including Uber, Airbnb, Instacart, Redit, and
Lyft just to name a few. And it’s unlikely that
these companies will move away from Twilio anytime
soon because Twilio has won over the developers
at these companies with their developer first
mindset. And, as long as Twilio has a strong
roster of customers it’s unlikely that investors
will stop supporting Twilio. Worst case scenario,
they have a couple of rough years until they
achieve profitability after which they’ll be
good to go. Also, Google and Amazon are by
no means trying to take down Twilio. In fact,
they actually support Twilio. Just recently,
Twilio partnered with Google to create better AI
powered virtual customer support. And Amazon has
even gone as far as investing in Twilio buying up
a 1% stake in the company. But, his could also be
perceived as bad news. You have a strong company
with strong customers that’s facing a cash flow
problem. That makes them a perfect acquisition
target. Google and Amazon could easily put up the
$12 billion to buy the company. And they would
have a far easier time handling the expenses
with their in house infrastructure. They may
even be able to achieve profitability with Twilio
but even if they don’t, it doesn’t really matter
because they would have a new list of customers
that they could sell Google Cloud or AWS to. For
the sake of Twilio and in hopes of preventing
big tech from controlling yet another industry,
hopefully, Twilio is able to make it through on
their own but only time will tell. One fallen
giant that’s seemingly beating the odds is
Nokia, check out this video to learn more.